hello everybody
Happy New Year happy 2018 to everybody
it's me Eric if you guys didn't know and
you guys are new viewers we are starting
off the year with an old friend one of
my old friends destiny - there is a new
whoa that looks kind of weird hold on
one second let me try to fix this real
quick
that looked a little wonky when we see
if this fixed it no it still looks wonky
hold on
[Music]
you know and everything's fine then you
come back and 2018 and everything's kind
of like not working
ah there we go I think I fixed it we got
a loose cable as Bob Jones says what's
up Sebastian Segura O'Neal Blackwell
Filippo Benz ciao banana cat boy what's
up everybody
leaf gate leaf face gamer well well are
gonna do the nightfall which is a garden
world this week there's torrent we're
like I think the third week in a row now
and time warp zero we're just gonna do
normal I'm doing it with Aaron and Joey
from the office here and I'm gonna hop
into some mayhem after this though
crucible for the daunting event you guys
want to hop in you can send me your
battle tags in a little bit and we'll do
that but for now we're gonna do the
night ball yeah I know right
tape popping out from under the desk
great starts of the year yep that's kind
of how it goes that's how it goes
what's up for Rondo's up Milano's thank
you for the Happy New Year banana cap
let's address the dirt dressy air gravy
this is one of the missions on Mercury
gameplays a little loud if I'm gonna run
through most of the first part is you
don't really need to do the first part
[Music]
trying to look at the what you guys are
getting the feed
you guys see something weird coming okay
I'm in the so fun fact if you want to
have a lot of fun in your Titan I would
go solar and I would let me change home
and and we're a hallow fire heart this
way you can spam grenades of crap you
are packing yep that's true that's what
I am
how was your day so far it's been oh not
bad it's it's weird adjusting to coming
back to work we had the holiday break a
week off which is nice thank you to our
company obviously for that
how come one looks a little bit some
type of Halo game it's made by Bungie so
I'm sure there's got some halophiles
there if you've never seen destiny yeah
we can spam grenades we can spam melees
I'm not gonna really worry about that
too much right now I'm trying to get
through this first part of the run it
gets a little bit harder later to skip
well you can skip a good amount of this
stuff I'm sorry that your life is not
going the way you want it to mode 3 but
hopefully 2018 is a better year for you
and you get more out of what you want
and like it's up Merc man is this a DLC
yes this is curse of Osiris but mainly
focusing on the weekly reset stuff which
is this week is a garden world for the
night both and
that's the netball and we're gonna also
do the mayhem pvp because it'll be the
last week we'll have mayhem for a while
because mayhem is tied to the daunting
event which ends up I believe my head
shots
can technically run by these they want
to be super safe and can be otherwise
they say otherwise it run by them like
okay this is not the up I'm gonna say
this is not the prestige so
we'll be fine plenty of time
well is your favorite Titan subclassed
says ask cosmic gumballs it's got to be
striker for sure I'm only playing solar
because with that armor that I have I
can spam grenades like almost instantly
because it's torn this week which allows
your abilities to recharge faster with
Paulo fire heart the chest as long as
you have full super all your abilities
come back even faster so as mentioned if
you want to have fun this week or if you
have you want to try doing the prestige
I'd try to pair it with like two solar
Titans or at least one other solar Titan
and just spam grenades you're crazy
you'll see me spamming grenades soon
because there is gonna be a point where
we're gonna have to kill some stuff and
not be able to just run by everything
I never thought I'd see how they're
poisoning the world with radiolaria I'm
reading arc energy at the pinnacle of
the spire I didn't have to look in your
chats and trace all gain sauce my favor
you see were great that's awesome thanks
Jason
tuning every day as we live stream every
day at 11 a.m. you'll usually swimmy you
might see some interfaces we're just old
faces this this year I'm gonna try to
get Sam on a scream she was on our extra
live stream maybe sometimes
you have to go back
again you don't have to kill this
something you don't want to just tell me
things those boxes
currently playing PC this week just so
you guys know for those that were
interested in potentially playing mayhem
it's definitely DLC Alfonso so
what's your most favorite weapon that's
hard to say I used to really like
nameless midnight whatever since I added
a master work weapon I've been using
better Devils I keep calling anyone
appreciates better than burials is
pretty cool calling me is actually
really fun and can you get yourself a
call and I finally got one last week but
it took me a couple faded engrams to
finally get one I still I have crimson
stuff like that happens that's what they
did in grams before I'll get it this
week for sure
cosmic gumballs likes the solar
sunbreaker which is solar tightening the
most because you like projectiles with
hammers I could see that I just think
that will pulse grenades really strong
outside of like when you have tourists
but yeah now personally still striker
for me especially since I changed a
super in g2 towards more than once match
it mayhem sunbreakers
because it's hard to get up and close up
close with the striker because there's a
lot of Nova bombers
we want to be able to go to college I
have to kill some stuff here
this gun is also really good positive
outlook if you haven't real see it has
kill clip and it pretty much is like a
Ariel's gift except guys go put man it
doesn't have high caliber rounds but
still clip Nick software and a nerf high
caliber anyways
crazy
it's
shoot that thing
once I hope you guys have had a good
2017 and if not I hope you have a better
2018
stay with us here at GameSpot as will be
as mentioned live streaming every day at
11 a.m. Pacific there's not too many
games or stuff we have too much earlier
this week so 5 play some old stuff
waiting for these guys to catch up
that's not gonna work out he's immune
oh hello
how does this bothers people the
expansion
count pickles hey I hope you had a
sufficiently drunk and Happy New Year
oh thanks I actually didn't get Oh
didn't get too drunk I had a pretty
chill just kind of like a game night
with some friends working button you
came called a joking hazard which is
kind of reminds me of oh please like
okay we all kind of reminds me of cards
against humanity' but it's like a it's
got a different play on it or a
different take slightly pretty fun if
you're interested I think that that'd be
a way to go oh I like the solar because
of the grenade thermite let's fire
thermite grenade which is the one I'm
using the one that throws a little fire
wave this one
their maker need is free legit
yeah so I had a pretty tame years powers
here guys
travel outside of your normal
like states
by the country
yeah wishing the cardigan
Oh hammers
oh I didn't use thingy
ah right nope too late oh my got it hey
I got it off oh it's because we did a
bunch of the challenge also I think
loves which I don't need to get through
35 yep and you know alright so that's
pretty good
is there anyone that wants to do mayhem
if you want to hit me up well so we just
got the clan clan Engram which is pretty
sweet
do you think there's going to be a
destiny 3 at some point probably but
there's still at least one more
expansion so hard to say a king crow is
retired from destiny why would you
retire miss Bennett needs this game
I think it's on sale right now should be
pretty pretty cheap
thanks Andreas for wish you all the best
for 2018 have a nice day thank you
appreciate that
alright well I'm gonna leave this here
for a second
I'm gonna see if anyone says anything if
not we'll just get to go and man
somebody's gaining clan xp for us though
which is pretty sweet
oh yeah I need a 335 heavy too I think
yep sucks
that's alright though do you have ps4
yes I normally actually play on ps4 but
here we'll launch one and see if anyone
joins it or wants to join after I
normally play on ps4 kokua but because
I'm 335 hun all three of my characters I
think on ps4 the only one might be
hunter but I think that one's 335 too I
decided why not let's spin up PC my
characters 334 I'm missing a Titan mark
I figure maybe we'll get that one count
count pickle says Eric you should play a
rimless Exige with Michael McCarty that
game is amazing yeah I probably should
is it doing that it's flickering again
I think it's still doing it I still see
like granularity at the bottom left all
right one side
sorry team
mayhem class
I need the luck checks I want to say
that fixed it no it is not fixed
I can't tell actually I'll have to check
in a second
you know what else is unfortunate
because I don't have colony all right
easy
No why say it fix it
not sure it'll be fine I actually
haven't been seeing too many people
doing the glitch which is interesting
like I have a shopping don't mind me
sooner rocket be bed 1988 what's their
gamertag please I need a Rachel
I barely write anymore I read like once
a week with my rage in PvP it like feels
good but like I'm just not used to it
it's like so much faster on PC too if
you if you haven't played ps4 and PC I'm
dead crap
usually one Nova doesn't kill or one
axiom bullet doesn't kill
what I get for using a pistol how bad do
you want me
just shadows shadow shut up you got me
with it
what
I got to pick something guys but each
okay hold on
it's good it's sorry I'm talking to an
engineer okay I tricked myself the last
few digits were the same as
that's fine I'm gonna replace it anyway
I think wasn't going out to the site
guys starting off 2018 strong fine we
are now that's what matters Oh God all
right do you think that's Tunisia to
deserves go t know I don't
it's a lot like so I like it because I
like this
mistake but it's not very similar to
Destin 1 so I can't really give it too
much other than the fact that it's out
on pc now if you were to ask me if there
was a game on pc that i would recommend
that someone play in 2018 I would
recommend destiny to if they've never
played destiny before but I don't think
it deserves go D we did our top 10 that
come on so yeah I mean you can check out
our top ten that list is up and I
apologize to any other GameSpot users
that we're trying to watch that couldn't
watch I screwed up okay
rocketing myself yep feeling good
no that sucks
waste three minutes remaining actually
one of my favorite weapons in PvP is
old-fashioned hand cannon evaded the
rocket
Oh Joey that was mine and we are losing
probably because I was afk for like a
good minute day
stuck me so live now I think we got a
Duke that guy is definitely colonizing
which stories buried ste
or destined to that stuff that's need to
probably taking King was really good
though
[Music]
nothing to see here I'm gonna get those
I just got hammered
no this is a waste of hammers
Oh from downtown oh we caught up boy
went right past him
okay gotta boat
oh there's more
how did that get him
oh we're so good oh we're good oh we're
winning though we're winning oh crap
yeah we just need one kill
oh that's mine yeah we did it
success don't call it a comeback how
many peeps so play destiny 1 I think
there's there's a decent there's still
some things in destiny 1 that are
probably better than that how did I end
up being first we're afk
why don't you play pub G in a stream oh
we used to do it more often I think
we're gonna bring it back I feel like
there's there's sounding a lot of people
that like pub G and we could definitely
potentially stream that on a weekly
basis so yeah again apologies to the
people on GameSpot I goofed it looks
very similar the livestream ID so yeah
sorry about that but I appreciate
everyone here and YouTube twitch and
gays vibe you guys haven't hit sub
subscribe on youtube you guys should do
that again we go live every day at 11
a.m. it'll notify you that of that and
then we also have a bunch of cool hot
features that we do and it's still
flickering I swear to god I know that's
not space the whole bottom left is
jacked right now hold on
now it's still doing it hold on
mayhem clash destroy them with your
light
I mean it's not super noticeable it's
just like noticeable the moon oh well it
is what it is for now I'll fix it before
tomorrow string
what Oh shotgun I was like that guy
didn't kill me do you like Halo our
Destiny's better I personally like
Destiny's better I just like the world
and the stuff you can do but to be
honest I really only played like Halo 5
and halo original because I owned a
Playstation
this will wait for rockets
Oh
surprise oh he has a curious I like that
I don't like that no there's so much
range on that shotgun funny thing is I
never got a curious on do you see only
have it on ps4 but the funny thing is I
have the skin for it oh you still have a
curious sure destroy it
dad yeah gadget is still here you're
talking about him getting his head
shaved for uh well trade yeah no more
aqueous fun for you
hammers for the
good save good save plan BOM keep our
streak alive it was good while it lasted
what's the minimal network suite to play
this high not super high right if you
have 10 down I play on crappy Wi-Fi
sometimes and I don't feel the lag too
much
they get him
that's like walks right into worlds yeah
I did do that didn't I oh no he's a
curious
Wow just aimed it at the corner who does
that
that's a hammer looks more like an axe
no it's a hammer this is a hammer for
sure shock him again
maybe you started a stuffing
I encounter lag well my boyfriend did
playing oh uh depends I mean like I said
I've played on wife is fine
I choked Nova versus Nova the dance of
the Nova are we are losing but barely
hopefully I can make some plays with the
Rockettes I won't number one
from downtown oh they one by one but I
got an exotic so there's that embrace
the salt yeah it's I live in the mines
every day in the salt mines they used to
do KTR or maybe it's because they have
all this other stuff that doesn't show
KTR but that sucks
hey shotguns more overpowered or rockets
probably rockets but a curious has
really long range and it does a lot of
damage it's the exotic shotgun how you
get from doing a long chain quest to to
the raid my opinion by halo is way
better than d1 was trash d2 is good but
halo has so much time built into its
story and it's characters are just so
much better yeah I could I don't
disagree with the character part of it
that's scenes whose multiplayer is
pretty good yeah I like it for the raids
and the dungeon is the stuff like I know
assists on the board who plays this
garbage I do I think a lot of people
still play I don't think as many people
play this before but it's what happens
[Music]
are you trying to play on PC cosmic if
you are you can send me your battle tag
and then I can add you to play a game or
two of mine well we finished that night
ball really enjoy yourself Guardians
okay I will add you after this game
gonna have to swap out of
close
okay at least we got her with me more
quickly Oh No
that looked like it was gonna hit oh
there's definitely a guy at passages set
no stroke to though
oh he's behind me isn't he
Captain America
no I just get them Joey
make them cry what Oh too late
oh no I don't know no make it back woo
got lucky wait
okay I guess he got it through the
little crevice there just hey your
gamertag notes on
No
so what's not going so well we'll take
it we got four pockets let's not mess
this up feel like I'm gonna mess it up
though I think I was like Aaron he's
trying to like oh no that should be a
triple no we had more Rockets we had all
of them such a good spawn
[ __ ] a pop super there
I think it's only behind me yep hammer
so what a ridiculous name
yeah old nova war there
whoa dodge your Captain America shield
you trying to Nova dangerous times
okay we got a fire streak how long will
it last
not that long I guess go get them
oh I can't wait to see what you do with
that oh where is he
all this might be a waste of a superb
I got baited but I don't know where the
hell you went because you should have
used this tether is he underneath okay I
don't get it whatever all questioning Oh
did I have fun playing the d1 campaign
not that much taken King campaign was
given I thought that was a solid one
feel like they learned a lot from that
one
I'm tethered and he has to use a super
that's funny she just shot you would
have gotten way more
this expansion is really disappointing
goodly I do agree with you I have two
views on that one payback Oh classical
music alright alright I think Aaron's
got first that time good job area 24
trash another battle one on to the next
fight
oh yes I got to add hold on back out of
this - and get one fellow into this
Wow v-net actually had a restart an
update
I'd do it from here I can no I can't
hope that works add a friend all right
let me scroll back up real quick let me
get that there's alright I just sent you
an invite
Kosmic you should see it there in a
second
hopefully and then you can just join on
me hopefully
mm oh there you go
- fireteam
damn this room is filling up with
posters yeah of course I need to put
more in
not enough cosmic gumball and how are we
not done with cold arms that's how bad
I'm playing I think I really wish I had
colony on this character it would just
ward cliff then I don't have to aim as
much
what class do you think is best um a
Skokie Monza I think Cookie Monster
maybe uh titanum warlock for sure
I think Hunter's got the has gotten the
shaft john luke says new poster he
ordered has just arrived that's good and
he has the shadow of colossus one framed
I guess yo do you have ps4 yes iron
spider plays I have ps4 too
well do you want expansions we're still
better than arguable because dark below
everyone didn't like the raid by the had
a raid and then House of wolves had
prison of elders which I would say most
people weren't super thrilled about but
it was different right
whereas what was this we got a red layer
which I thought the rail layer actually
is really good everything else is kind
of like subpar mediocre heroic strikes
aren't even as good as they used to be
Indy
run
oh oh yes it's explosive ones
oh it's a rocket tad is a rocket
no we missed with word flip
that feeling about this
I'm miss
oh yeah switch back the game screen best
IRL stream ever 2018 still learning it's
still a pulpy
nice gameplay yeah I know right it's
okay you guys didn't miss much I didn't
I didn't
Oh sewed in a vortex community Oh
surprisingly close so much action I know
right feels good feels good feels good
feels good all right I'm throwing for
the team right now people still play
this game yeah Wow nice FPS ps4 is 30
yep yes that piece is pretty good pretty
good stuff should open your own channel
ID
I was that guy not dead
nice Mele there
from downtown two-for-one
Oh run nobody's coming
I should his father probably there was
no reason around
rip the eight yeah
where they act my hammer is is cooking
away
oh I wasn't worth challenging didn't
know yet Golden Gun on
three minutes
you're evenly matched yes weird clip why
this could be a mistake
we're good
oh it's so close I don't have a super
what are you super no he's so close to
dying
I heard a shadow shot
come on
there's a wasted supers there's no way
he's not dead right okay no oh no they
hammers first just run they can't even
hear me
all right I got a place I got to play
better why is it Hank Canyon for primary
I don't know I just like better Devils
actually if anything positive outlook or
areal positive outlook it's because my
outlooks master worked but here we'll
use old fashioned it'll do better than
Devils oh that did nothing whoops I
don't want to do that yeah that's fine
all right war cliff did not get it done
what's your favorite game of all time
Diablo 2 probably dropped a dislike and
now I'm gone all right later Darren
brown thank you am i paying a oh no
that's something else yeah I'm really
not milestone 97
probably playing for about one or two
more matches and so we just got cosmic
in and then we'll play stop there's a
few Hank actually I feel like hand
cannon on PCs better than it is on
console suddenly more precise and so if
you're good with hand cannons with the
mouse I would say hand cannon is way
better but you know autos are so pretty
good
Orioles is still pretty good out looks
good Diablo - you probably favorite game
of all time mayhem clash enjoy yourself
Guardians
alright another beast mode beast mode
beast
Aaron get him side bus them Oh No
I choked that last shot I had Devils on
it he would have died yeah was it
explosive I've not used my super yet
which is kind of silly
multiplayer is definitely better than
show your enemy what a real fight
all right we got to do we got to get
this we gotta get this going
all right
you wouldn't work with the rocket right
now I just gotta be real
Oh building guns I'm running he's going
for the rockets that did though
taking the lead don't mind me I'm just
playing team fortress we had so many
rockets which exact weapon is your
favorite primary and secondary
[Music]
from d2
I am right there whoo primary maybe Jade
rabbit cuz I just have this thing with
they drive it from v1 heavy you probably
colonies in the bunnies
anything a secondary I actually don't
even use on any exotic weapons anymore
[Music]
were cliff is pretty fun too
in terms of armor sculpt work Orpheus
Riggs is really good no no don't go that
way
every way
I should have killed them way sooner
though you never saw me
wow we're getting rekt how we were doing
so well ever since I stopped killing
with Rockets it kind of like spies I can
kill him with not having enough
oh I should just challenge Wow we got
destroyed that game how's the worst game
yet the only bad result is a tie don't
be discouraged
yeah cosmic it's always gonna have delay
stream versus real time but your
favorite game with 2017 a slap with the
dummy got to be breath of the wild it
was my number one it was game sports
number one I think that some some of the
games that I would put on there that I
think one of the loans that didn't make
our top ten was Neil I really like Neil
how's it going all good cosmyk we just
got to play better and by we I mean
collectively our team needs to play
better I need to play better 14 kills is
not enough to get us what we need
cuphead got the snow kind of I tried to
defend it it was close it was it was
closed it had a chance at like 10 and
then it just fell out of the top time I
tried to I tried with a little bit of
joeys help to save it but we didn't
unfortunately we were not able to save
it do you think destiny 2 should
introduce its own forge mode like Halo
um probably not but you never know
that man's not happy this game
it's unfortunate Batman but your you're
a crime-stopping Crusader and you should
probably be worrying about saving Gotham
more so than playing destiny too but I
appreciate your opinion on the game
thank you for stopping by
agent Allen 15 I guess you don't have
work today
see why I'm gonna go
alright this will probably be our last
match here so let's try to win it or I
guess I should make the stipulation I
can't stop until we win I could be risky
though I feel good about it that I feel
good all right so they got some of the
same people on their team and the Juber
was the
Oh sneaky sneaking in
feel it in your bones the show we're
having
oh he still has his gun
this
got me with this shadow shot would you
want another hive DLC hi spine it's been
a while since we bought the hive
I enjoy killing them
downtown
looks like Annie might be okay with
dying
all right so I didn't get that one guy
he's I didn't kill that guy that would
be felt real bad
oh no the guy hi there
you're in the lead
come on it flew out of my hand I swear
Oh God
come on
I don't even know which ones my fire
trails
Oh Lord Wow how did how did they
suddenly get it so far ahead
Oh
I'm so good
you'll be seated alright I guess we got
to play one more I swear I killed so
many I killed so many what is his name
yeah I had 22 that time like 100 I
supposed to do all right
a streak streak streak not fast enough
yeah and if you could bring one gun from
destiny to to destined to you from other
FPS games which would you choose
let's talk help you someone said BFG I
think said Tom that's very good
oh I like um I like the micro missiles
alive in the last doom that was on the
assault rifle because he was like what's
up yellow Sanchez
they bring a bigger backpack tape all
right I'll bring a bigger backpack
mayhem is cray-cray
Aaron done cleaning it is pretty cray
cray I sub thanks unlimited beast
welcome to the game spots all right you
gotta bring a bigger backpack I'm being
told I need a bigger backpack so I'm
gonna bring a bigger backpack it's time
to do that yeah I still see what it is
oh god I just ran by city girl huh yeah
no I was done I looked at Jeff that was
doesn't stick
you get the lead it really comes down to
how many heavy kills you get and how
many super kills you get because I
wouldn't say I wouldn't call Bungie out
necessarily trapping Kirkwall for that I
mean they're owned by another company
who is after the money I think
he's behind me the entire time
don't spend all that ammo in one place
where did he go stick with the hammer
oh I am sick of him
two shotguns lip
instead of bad place to be
oh man i Stinky's nice gameplay gotta go
later cookie guns are from Pakistan
thank you for tuning in from Pakistan
appreciated look like calling me put
this toes
buble let's go
all right we're back in and we're back
in two boys let's go
Paul hawthorne's
and we're down ten in a blink of a lie
we're down ten now
all right you brought a sniper I brought
a rocket launcher that's just how it
goes
Golden Gun no why are you over there
yeah I agree traveling Travon I can't
just beat that
three minutes no I ran out of bullets
great play good play by that gosh
don't let your enemy take this without a
fight
okay come on team I heard Golden Gun
that's not good
no I did the demon souls one yes
all right well can't say we didn't try I
swear it it's about me it's flickering
yeah
I tried I tried it was a good run guys
it was a good run thank you guys all for
tuning in that's our destiny to weekly
shreem last week of the dawning check
that out if you haven't last week of
mayhem as we were just playing and we'll
probably be back tomorrow maybe actually
that's probably not true because
normally tomorrow is the lobby we're not
gonna do the lobby this week hopefully
we do it next week we're doing some
stuff in the studio so it's gonna take
us a little bit of time but I appreciate
everyone tuning in and until next time
thank you for all the technical hiccups
today - well we'll try to get rid of
those come the rest of the week
welcome 2018 hope you guys had a good
day and have a good rest of your day
bye bye
[Music]